good evening two men in las vegas
arrested for the january 6 riot in
washington d.c went in front of a judge
for the first time
today thanks for joining us i'm denise
valdes and i'm brian loftis nathaniel
degrave and ronald sandlin facing
multiple federal
charges all in connection to the
storming of the capitol orco mana has
more now from court
court documents reveal the fbi arrested
nathaniel degrave and ronald sandlin
last week at degrave's apartment
both are accused of illegally entering
the u.s capitol during the january
6 insurrection degrave who lives in las
vegas is seen here wearing full tactical
gear he's also seen in surveillance
footage from
inside the capitol building sandlin who
authorities say is from tennessee went
viral for these images showing him
apparently smoking marijuana inside the
capitol
in court monday prosecutors called the
defendant's actions quote
extremely troubling adding the evidence
against them is overwhelming
that includes an alleged shoving match
with capitol police and social media
posts which prosecutors say show
premeditation
just being around him as a person all of
these little red flags
drew schroeder tells me he's degrades
former business partner he describes the
grave as unhinged
i think it's so wrong for people to be
storming the capitol
and and the more people that they
catch and they bring to justice the
better lawyers for both defendants
wanted them to be on house arrest
claiming they're not dangerous but the
judge decided they're both flight risks
so they'll remain detained
a preliminary hearing for the grave has
been set for february 16.
reporting from the federal courthouse
orcomanna 8 news now